it is all about a celebration a
celebration of fiesta tigres and a
celebration we hope to get miguel
cabrera to 500 in detroit let's take a
look at tigers chucker tonight willie
peralta 12th appearance 11th with the
tigers and a big difference in how he
pitches and his pitch performs he's got
what we call reverse split so you look
at cleveland's lineup chef only two
lefties against the right-handed
pitching peralta because he gets lefties
out so righties
it's what we call a reverse split
reyes on the ground to third
candelario sharp last night and a sharp
way to start here this saturday night
good job by willie peralta 12 pitches
and the first is through for cleveland
miguel cabrera that's third chasing 500.
well sam henches is going to be uh the
indian starting pitcher tonight again
you see the numbers this will be his
tenth start of course this is gonna he
was on about a 40
count his last outing on tuesday i'm
sure it's going to be similar again
today if he can get through it
so we'll see what he has to offer
tonight
swinging a miss at a high fast ball and
he strikes him out to start
nice wow really good slow breaking ball
all fastballs to that last pitch crowd
doesn't seem to mind because of this
everyone's standing
drilled to left
a base hit for cabrera
now 49 hits away from 3 000
as he continues to chase milestones
here's jamer candelario
the 2-0 pounded deep left field that
ball's gone
a two-run shot and jamer candelario has
pushed the tigers in front
ninth homer of the year for candelario
he gets a heater tries to sneak it in on
him and candy is quick
didn't take long
and the payoff pitch
came back with a curveball but he missed
down low nice patient at bat and he
walks the lead off man so the buffalo
will stampede down to first oscar
mercado coming to the plate
that's a fair ball another left field
line mercado can run he's on his way to
second at least he's going to probably
turn and burn and he puts on the brakes
but the buffalo scores all the way from
first
and the indians come right back and
answer the tigers with a run here in the
second and the tying run is at second
base with nobody else
well there you have it i mean he got
another fastball inside that he roped
down the line mercado with his sixth
double
now the payoff he struck him out
first punch out of the night for willie
peralta comes at a perfect time that's
running down knight is young though way
out in front and he strikes out jimenez
didn't give in he's cool character
the one-two he got him swinging
cleveland leads the tying run at third
good job by peralta got in a bit of a
bind early and then struck out chang
jimenez and clement here's willy castro
a blooper to right and that'll
drop dinker right there over the
first baseman's head in in front of the
right fielder and he's dangerous on the
base pass got good speed see how much
pressure the tiger is trying to put on
wilson ramos there we go right away the
first pitch and castro is in there
safely ramos came out of there quick
yeah he sure did
no that string doesn't count he was
already on there with the hand
they're not going to try it now indians
will not challenge it quickly a runner
in scoring position for the tigers with
only one out
looper to right center
that's down
castro's being waved home
he will hustle home without a throw and
the tigers
are up 3-1 on the rbi single from victor
reyes
good pitch slow curveball and just
locked him up third k for hinches
another run for detroit they lead it 3-1
see if willie peralta can get out of it
by retiring wilson ramos there he goes
he's struck him out
what a job by willie peralta
a lead-off double followed by a single
and then peralta induces a couple of
fly-outs and punches out ramos 3-1
tigers cabrera that's second one up and
one down and here comes miggy
the 2-2 fly ball deep center field
straw's got room
and he gathers it
oh he had one there
here's willy castro
first pitch swinging
nice play by ernie clement and the relay
is in time to give willy castro what a
way to turn two for cleveland could have
checked that
aj hinch wants him to look at it
he's safe yeah you would guess this one
gets overturned
looks like there's clear and convincing
evidence that the call on the field is
incorrect
he's out he's safe
[Applause]
he's gone what a jump
the throw to second no way
jack short looking to hit a gap here
square a couple
good wheels on the bases
short to center field
that's down willy castro will try and
score straw's throw is cut off and zach
short comes through
here we go again with runners in scoring
position jose ramirez another
opportunity
get on the board there's a fly ball deep
right center field that's in the
elliott's up against the wall
scoring easily is straw and jose racing
around second digging for third the ball
gets away from scope momentarily it's an
rbi triple for jose ramirez and a 4-2
ball game
well you knew it's just a matter of time
he didn't hesitate jumped on that first
pitch plugged it into triple's alley so
now it's reyes's turn
there's a line driving a base hitting
the right field and it's a one-run game
reyes breaks the schneid he was over his
last 19 before that rbi hit
he brings home ramirez
and the indians have scored twice here
in the fifth inning
cabrera will lead off line drive singled
his first time out fly ball to center
his last time up against two different
pitchers
the 2-1 oh we hit him
i don't think the crowd liked it i was
wondering what would happen if somebody
walked miggy you know just they would
boo but i never thought about somebody
hitting them
jose cestero
zimmer bunts bare hand grab and throw
not in time put it in your pocket an
outstanding drag bunt there
rip to
the gap right center that gets down cut
off by reyes zimmer on his way to third
he'll stop there it's a double for jose
ramirez and they are set up here in
inning number seven
now it's up to ramos
and a ground ball routine to short
that'll tie the game
two down wilson ramos picks up rbi
number 17. there you go an easy rbi with
a ground out to short
big moment to lead off the eighth
3-2
in the dirt cabrera leads off the eighth
with a walk
jacob robson will pinch run for miguel
cabrera what an environment to play in
tonight boys man
good job by miguel had some huge hats
the 01 to candelario broken bat up the
middle through
into center field
second nobody out
power hitters do up next nunez
the 1-0
up the middle base hit
robson had to hold and he will hold at
third the bases are loaded with tigers
for eric haas
[Applause]
the 2-1
a blooper
that's down
robson scores here comes candelario huss
comes through in the eighth
[Applause]
crowd ready to celebrate a win
soto against fran mill reyes
ball game
these type of games with all the
excitement
i think these guys will all realize it's
going to be a little
probably a little more tired when you
kind of finally wind down tonight but
tomorrow we step in here he's gonna do
it all over again gibby that's the first
time the indians were retired one two
three all night long tigers even up the
series 6-4